Karate kicking Jesus, Time-traveling rollerbladers, and whatever the hell this is
"No! Here comes the baby"
[whoosh sounds]
Doom Patrol Season 2 is here with a new home on HBO Max
And if you haven't heard the news, episode 9 wasn't originally supposed to be the season finale because of COVID they didn't get to film
All of the final episode so, if it felt a bit like this wasn't a finale
That's probably why. Either way, we're going to take a deep dive into this finale and try to answer some of its biggest questions
Like, who this mystery alter ego is? Why Niles had a syringe on him?
And of course, Dorothy and the Candlemaker. But, before we get ready to party, make sure to like and subscribe
Lexmantello demands it.
The final episode focuses on Crazy Jane, or should I say
Miranda, who has taken control of Kaye's body as the primary. Think of the primary as the captain of K's
alter egos and part of Jane's arc
this season was all about letting go and accepting Miranda as the best person to handle Kay's protection
"You were so much stronger than I would have ever been from now on I'll fall in line". Of course
that's right before she's pushed down the well to drown for all eternity. As we find out in arguably the biggest twist of the season
Miranda isn't Miranda at all. In fact, the real Miranda died down the well decades ago. So, who is this mystery woman
who has infiltrated K's alter egos?
My theory is that it's the Candlemaker manifesting a version of K's abusive father. In the last episode
we saw how Vic, Rita, and Cliff all faced off against their quote-unquote imaginary friends
But, really it was all the Candlemaker's doing. Who's to say that the Candlemaker isn't controlling this alter ego somehow?
Let's remember that this fake Miranda first appeared after the Candlemaker made it into the
underground and killed Baby Doll and Flaming Katie, that's one hell of a coincidence
If it turns out the Candlemaker isn't in control
And of course, the Candlemaker would use Kaye's biggest trauma, the abuse of her father
against her and what better way to infiltrate Kay's body and personalities than by manifesting as the alter ego, The Protector
who stood up to that abusive father. "I told you I don't want to hear none of that Miranda crap no more"
What I'm trying to say here is that this alter ego is a version of her father
controlled by the Candlemaker and we definitely know there's some father elements by what the fake Miranda says here
"And who are you?"
[Eerie Music]
"Sweet baby". That line "sweet baby" is what her father used to call her as a child
And if you go all the way back to season 1, episode 9 where Jane confronts her father, it's on full display
"Sweet, sweet, baby Kay"
"Sweet sweet, baby"
"Sweet, sweet baby", But all this really doesn't matter because Kay's body is completely covered in wax
It doesn't matter who's in control. If there's no body to control in the first place. Here's where things get a little more interesting
"It's behind me, isn't it?"
The only person who is still standing at the end of the episode and yes, that's a terrible,
terrible pun is Niles Calder and I think the key to what happens next lies in this very quick shot of Niles holding a syringe
Obviously, this will come into play
He wouldn't just randomly bring a syringe to a carnival with his daughter unless he planned on using it, perhaps on her. Now
what's in it? My best guess is that it's the same serum used to suppress crazy Jane's powers. The concoction
that was put together by Joshua Clay in season 1 that Niles said this season is all gone
So, who would he use it on? Doesn't really make sense to use it on himself and Dorothy's already gone with the Candlemaker
So, maybe he'll have to use it on Jane to suppress the Candlemaker taking over her body
There are also two wild cards out there that could possibly play a role in what happens next. The first is Mr.
Nobody. All we know about him
this season is that he's made it out of the painting and unavailable because he's working on the Harley Quinn animated series
This is just a fun nod to the actor who plays Mr. Nobody:  Alan Tudyk
I hope I'm saying that right, voicing one of the characters on that show. "Did you just call me a fudger?" Mr.
Nobody is insanely powerful and there's no way he'd want the world to end. So, it's definitely possible
we'll see him return to join forces with the Doom Patrol
The second wild card is Danny the Brick who we last saw turn into a tire at the end of episode 4
now in the comics, he later turns into Danny the
Ambulance and perhaps that tire is hinting at what he's going to turn into and the Doom Patrol
Does look like it could use an ambulance right about now and if Danny arrives so, too will the Danny Zinns like Flex Mantello
who can make things appear out of thin air
Probably a good thing to have in this situation as things look increasingly grim for the Doom Patrol. It seems their only
Hope is Dorothy, who at the end of the season goes to take on the Candlemaker by herself
Something Niles says she isn't ready for, in fact, Dorothy's character arc is all about growing up. She's actually
103 quarter years old but, is in the body of an 11-year-old. This slow growth Niles attributes to her being the daughter of
Slava, an immortal survivor of an ancient tribe and Slava's reappearance near the end of the season indicates her and likely her people
have something to do with the Candlemaker. Slava wants Dorothy to grow up and fight him almost as if it's some sort of ritual
bringing her into womanhood and bonus points if you clock the boots
she puts on are ruby color
Just like Dorothy's Ruby Slippers in the Wizard of Oz. Will those boots like Dorothy's and Oz be her way back to the real world?
And that brings us to Who the Candlemaker really is? In the comics
He's an extra-dimensional being that is the physical representation of fear such as World War 3 or Nuclear Bombs
He wasn't a threat because he couldn't travel to the physical world
But, he's now found a way through Dorothy's power of making imaginary creatures come to life
As witnessed throughout the season, The Candlemaker can grant wishes
But, these wishes come at great expense which is why Nile says she must never make a wish
In the comics, The Candlemaker allows three wishes kind of like a genie and it just so happens
She uses her final wish to bring back
Joshua Clay, one of the murdered Doom Patrol members. Add that to the list of reasons
we may see him again. Upon using her final wish, The Candlemaker gets its freedom into the physical world
which is what dorothy is wanting to stop. Now, I don't think The Candlemaker is going to kill Dorothy
He needs Dorothy in order to get into the physical world
her power is what makes it possible for him to live, but I do want to talk about the
Candlemaker's last line where he tells Dorothy it's time for her to meet her fate.
Does he know what she'll become, what she'll be
responsible for? Will he even try to sway her against Niles and the Doom Patrol?
After all
It was Niles who kept her hidden away on Danny Street for decades almost like a prisoner. Now, I also see the show introducing a
Time Travel element and there are some clues that hint towards this
Time has played a huge role this season. Niles wants to slow down Dorothy growing up and wears a Longevity
Talisman, something he trades to Willoughby Kipling in order to return the Doom Patrol members to their natural size
There's also an interesting episode where Rita and Cliff have to take on a Dr. Time who controls a rare time-bending element called
continuinium. Not to mention how the show utilizes countless flashbacks
But, it's the fact Cliff won't be able to make his daughter Clara's wedding that leads me to believe time travel might just happen
I mean
It would be the perfect ending if a time travel element were introduced and Cliff and the Doom Patrol are both
able to save the day and he's able to go to his daughter's wedding
We also have Larry's interesting meeting with Moscow a space traveler who like him,
also went into that field of energy that irradiated his body but, unlike him she has learned to control the energy,
become one with it, and was able to do this in five years
It's been decades for Larry. So, did time play a factor here? We know how time and space can be funky
Like, did you even see interstellar?
And is this a hint that we'll soon see a more normal-looking version of Larry? Doom
Patrol's character arcs are what set apart this show from most of the other superhero shows and movies out there
These characters are well developed with rich flaws that they have to overcome
Rita has to believe that she isn't a fraud and overcome the trauma of watching her mom bang a producer
Larry tries to rekindle his relationship with his family only to be backstabbed by those he loves
Vic tries to navigate his own trauma and falls in love with a woman with a murderous past
And Cliff tries to be the father
his father never was. It's really interesting to watch these characters grow and how their traumas inform their decisions
But, one main thread that ties all these characters together is family. All of them have either hurt
or have been hurt by their real families so much so that The Doom Patrol itself becomes a pseudo-family. They're all that
they got and I think that's part of the reason why we care about them so much
We've seen the pain
they've gone through and we want to see them succeed. And I know that I will be in pain if there isn't a season three
So, I hope you'll give this video a like and subscribe and comment below your thoughts and theories for next season
you can also follow me on twitter at
ThinkStoryYT
Until next time remember, Daddy loves you very much
[Outro Music]